my name is moonlit I'm a partner develop
manager Google Play specialising in
games I am keenly aware that I am one
the last two things standing between you
and happy hour
so let's look something fun what are
some the recent transit innovation in
mobile gaming specifically genre mashing
and subscriptions you probably noticed
my cheerleading squad sitting here we're
lucky to have Lauren Chris and Charles
from three of our top partners join me
on stage you hear from each one of them
there's stories of innovation but first
let me set the stage today we'll cover
these three things first I'll give you
an overview of the global trends around
our mashing within mobile gaming second
we'll show you that this trend is not
limited to just mashing games our three
guests here will show you how they took
dollar mashing be young gay mning by
bringing three very different industries
and last will touch on a little bit
monetization innovation recently namely
subscriptions in mobile gaming all right
let's how about our matching within
gaming the idea of combining multiple
core game loops into the same game on
mobile it's not a recent phenomenon in
2012 gung-ho swept the world with launch
of puzzle & Dragons The Godfather of
puzzle RPG Lane 2014 summoners war by
come to us kick-started the era of CC
RPG work hard collecting RPG
he also kick-started the era of LOM
acronyms in mobile gaming so considers
the floor warning for the amount of
acronyms I'm going to use in the next
five minutes today genre mashing happens
all over the world in mobile gaming from
the most casual to core to beyond gaming
next I'll share with you some
testimonies and case studies from a top
mobile
developers around the world and the more
casual and we have rodeo Stampede an
endless-runner game with builder meta
featherweight the Australian developer
with Yodle won the Chinese publisher
he's John rematching as a way to
differentiate turning something that
would have been a subtle twist into
something much more unique the game this
innovation has won them multiple awards
and helped again go viral
globally gardenscape is probably one of
those might most iconic successes of
Dharma mashing in mobile gaming clerics
the Russian game developer seed are
emerging as a way to stand out from the
crowded and established market something
we also observed earlier
Emily's talk on through risking your
launch clerics brilliantly interweaves
to core games their core audience loves
match three and builder the result is
incredible player love loyalty and
growth the game is top grossing globally
including Asia now moving on to slightly
more core Castle crushed by TFG a
Brazilian game developer combine the
elements of combat strategy game with
that a traditional trading card game can
I like Magic the Gathering the game only
launched in June this year and already
hasn't won the five million installs
with a 4.5 star rating Lords mobile is a
real-time MMO a strategy game with the
colorful elements of an RPG igg the game
developer sees our mashing as a way to
meet the demand of their users for more
sophisticated games the Altos es a way
to bring new experience for users who
may otherwise not try a different genre
magic rush by moon toon elack's Chinese
developer and publisher is a fresh
combination of three
genres mutan created magic rush as a
global entry point
by studying user pattern and demand
around the globe they learned that RPG
has been popular in Asia
whereas Compaq strategy games performed
really well in Europe and America so
magic rush was born as a way to improve
upon the elements of RPG with a swipe
action of tower defense games and social
appeal of SLG but enough talking about
mashing games I want to turn it over to
my guys speakers who'll share with you
how they reinvented fun by mashing
gaming with three very different
industries first we'll hear from Pocket
gems about episode interactive a game
that's turning into a new medium for
storytelling and then we'll have Crowell
star to tell you about the recent hit
design home which presents mobile game
as a canvas for design and creativity
and last we'll hear from Workshop about
how they're turning mobile gaming into a
new channel for music these are my star
presenters first as a welcome lauren
luke from pocket gems thanks hi everyone
I'm Lauren I'm with pocket gems
storytelling is at the core of what we
do one of the games I'm going to be
talking about today is episode so
storytelling itself isn't new it's
evolved over the course of thousands of
years it's crossed cultures generations
continents and it's existed in many
complex forms and when we look at its
modern-day shape what we're looking at
right now is storytelling in mobile
games episode is the world's largest
network for stories created on mobile
right now we have 73 thousand stories
with four billion episodes viewed we
started back in 2014 as a format for
story building that was built from the
ground up for mobile this format is
still in its very early days which is
very clear when you look at other forms
of modern storytelling like television
and movies episode is built for mobile
meaning that it has a portrait format it
allows for bite-sized consumption and
it's user driven you can think of it as
snapchat meets Netflix like snapchat
it's an interactive entertainment built
for mobile like Netflix episode is home
to a network of Hollywood caliber
stories we've been inspired by both
novels and comics our stories are
interactive and also animated but we're
not what we're not limited by print
technology we've also drawn from
television and movies we have engaged in
stories sometimes even spun by Hollywood
writers but users control their own pace
and how they engage with the story
episode is loved by a mobile-only
generation which is comprised largely of
Generation Z which is just now coming of
age in a survey that we did of 36,000
people aged 13 through 25 in the US we
found that for women 13 through 25 14%
are using their phones for more than 12
hours a day 11% are somehow checking
their phones in the shower and of those
aged 13 through 17 12% checked their
phones every few seconds so mobile now
needs a native format to address how
this generation interacts with real
stories this is a group that's grown up
entirely with smartphones meaning that
they have always actively participated
in how they receive their entertainment
so whether it's sending snaps to friends
going climbing with VR or watching a
video on musically they expect their
entertainment to be both interactive and
visual we've also been working with a
handful of IP partners as Hollywood has
taken successful books and made them
into legendary film franchises such as
Harry Potter and Twilight episode is now
the first to take great TV and movie
franchises and bring them natively to
mobile in 2015 we partnered with
Paramount to bring Mean Girls to episode
in 2016 we worked with our friends over
at Warner Brothers to release Pretty
Little Liars
and this year we're thrilled to be
working with Universal to introduce
pitch-perfect on mobile to the world so
this will be out in the next few months
keep an eye open for it
and with these franchise launches
episode has begun to establish itself as
an industry model bringing fans the
ability to actually be part of stories
that have these cult followings as
YouTube's led to the rise of streamers
and snapchats given way to a new kind of
social celebrity episode has also formed
a new class of creators we've shared our
storytelling tools and made them
available to all who are in episode
episode creators are now building their
own long-form narrative stories right
now we have over 8 million creators who
are telling their own stories within the
app and there are 5 million weekly
active users who are reading episode
original stories as well as these
Hollywood inspired stories so as we
continue to build episode we are
thinking constantly not only of the
stories that we're bringing to the world
but of this community of storytellers
and we're thrilled to be part of the
special and unique opportunity to help
give storytellers both a platform and a
voice Thank You next next up we've got
Chris from crowd star thanks Lauren
thank you hi I'm Chris I'm the GM of
design home I'm super excited to be here
I want to thank moonlit I want to thank
cliff I want to thank Emily for the
opportunity Google has been an
unbelievable partner to us we're a
little different and they've really
gotten us and I super appreciate it
before I talk well design home is a 3d
interior design game it's essentially an
endless doll house but for grown-ups and
before I talk about design home I want
to talk a little bit about the
philosophy of the studio I work for
called crowd star because Christ stars
actually been mashing up reality-based
design games for five years first with
the hit cover fashion and the fashion
space which after five years is still
going very strong and now with design
home which we
about eleven months ago and to be honest
with you
Krauser was born in a moment of
desperation or at least the current
iteration of crowd star when they
realized that they had better do
something different and something bold
or they were going to die a certain
death and what they did and I wasn't
there at the time is really look for the
white space and what they found was
there was a huge segment of people that
were totally underserved by the gaming
market in something that not only would
enthrall them but also would help them
in the real life and that segment was
women not girls but women and they have
a different mindset really these are
women who are coming into their own
financially they are highly engaged
highly creative they often are focused
on somebody on people that aren't always
themselves namely families and this is a
creative canvas for them to to not only
express their creativity but apply it to
real life and it's a positive sum game
we always make sure is a positive sum
game okay so what do we do when we
partner with real brands we model real
products and we put them into 3d
settings we're essentially changing the
conversation between makers and
consumers so that makers aren't just
talking at consumers their give we're
giving the consumers a chance to play
with products in a fun atmosphere and
then it always comes with links so that
you can buy things in the real world so
for example we have dozens and dozens of
real furniture partners some bakes when
and then we also go and find niche
boutiques and to date we've modeled
6,700 products and that grows every
single day it's a very simple game loop
it's shop design win right it opens up a
world of content experiences that you
just can't do you get
you can't do in your own home you get to
mix-and-match and visualize completed
designs in a way that mood boards could
never duplicate we launched five
challenges handcrafted challenges a day
and they stay open for three days and
once you're done with your design you
submit it and it gets scored frankly by
by the audience so it goes in and other
people vote on what's good and what's
not you get back your score you get in
virtual prizes so everybody's happy and
then you also see what the winning
designs were the highest scores well you
can see what you might have done better
or what goes with what
so there's always a learning experience
and it's a mixture of highly relatable
settings whether it's a suburban house
in Erie Pennsylvania to an apartment in
New York - you know aspirational so
headings like a tropical island and then
we have some fantasy settings so you
could be designing a moon base or like a
Christmas time one of my personal
favorites was you did the interior of a
gingerbread house it's simple and it's
fun but it turns out that modeling
reality is really hard and I'm blessed
to work with some incredible producers
engineers and artists because the
standards that you have to reach to
model reality are really high these are
not style stylized characters running
around this screen you have to figure
out not only model the furniture and the
decor perfectly but the room has to fit
you have to figure out the lighting you
have to figure out the shadows and how
everything is going to go together when
you have thousands of products that the
the user might use so and then you have
to also run a very hand crafted LiveOps
which is just really intense and again
I'm super blessed with the people that I
work with and while we're happy with the
aesthetics now you can imagine where
this space is going I mean our objective
is to be able to fall into the room to
taste the air in the room
and with a our VR and lots of other
possible arts coming it's a pretty
exciting and dynamic space we're pretty
pretty I'm enthrall them really where it
can go so so far we were launched in
November 15 so we're coming up on our
one-year birthday through June which is
what I can talk about now that we're a
publicly traded company because we're
acquired by glue we've had 25 million
downloads we've exceeded a million users
every day done a little more than 40
million dollars in bookings but I think
really most interesting thing is that
our users are generating more than 2
million handcrafted rooms a day we built
the house of over 500 million rooms I
think we're just getting started and
thanks for your time I'll buy you a
drink at the bar if later now you heard
from workshop how they're thinking about
their subscription design I want to also
share with you some best practices there
are two main ways of using subscription
in your mobile games one we have
subscription VIP - we have subscription
i 8p promised i'm not going to wrap
subscription VIP it's all about the high
value users these users are motivated by
prestige vanity loyalty rewards so year
ago as a developer it's really increased
long-term retention total revenue the
loyalty from the payers and also other
players some examples of subscription
VIP design include exclusive and/or
early access to special content specific
specific and special promos for these
subscribers and also higher daily caps
for a subscription I a P you should be
thinking about targeting everybody else
but especially the non buyers these
people are motivated by getting a good
financial deal so your goal as a
developer is to really increase buyer
retention and cultivate the habit of
logging in daily to increase your
altitude
so some example of subscription I a P
design include having a skew of gems
that pay out over several periods of
time several days for example this will
help players come back in and log in
daily to claim the rewards as with all
subscription monetization design really
keep track of the downsides be careful
of cannibalization and keep a close
pulse of a-pillar sentiment on my
community now talking about trans
innovations fun I want to leave you with
something to take with you as you head
into a happy hour after the next session
so let's summarize genre mashing should
be used for one differentiation or two
as a new way to consume content
subscriptions should be used for one VIP
to identify VIP to encourage engagement
to increase loyalty a subscription IEP
should be used to offer a good deal for
people who might otherwise not spend in
your games now thank you and thanks
Lauren thanks Charles and Chris for
amazing talk and sharing with us
experience let's give them another puff
you